the Chess Club Invitational had a bit of
an anti-climactic finish here today in
st. Louis both the GM and i am norm
section did not have a clear winner and
yesterday we found out that no players
would end up with a norm at the end of
this tournament in the Grandmaster norm
section you can see that the ims
outplayed the GMS for the most part and
at the very top international masters
zerk sarkar and nemer will split the
prize money in one of the harder fought
draws in the final round priyadarshan
and diamant just could not clear each
other that's all yeah and I didn't
expect after night b5 I was that was
kind of surprising to me disposition I
thought maybe you would play somehow
efore or something i thoughti for was
interesting here they are evil i was
thinking of be four night 8 for Bishop
d7 I know but this is a side this will
be interesting to me that prefer black
here Adam I can white should be slightly
better just d take C 5d take 35 Bishop
takes or maybe Queen takes a fiendish ok
for b.tech safe for Queen xhit a night e
you lose the bishop around because you
have to play Queen takes a for something
then I'd play take the e74 then see
fanatics was hanging that's what I was
calculating look down clear to me
I was a learning to play an IT eight if
this position if this has happened but
those are looking for me i have this
night stalking a floor latina blood
sookie know and maybe I mean I was just
calculating this an ID feels like
surprise to me when you just exchange
the pieces g5 yeah this was what I think
it's rock moves g4 yeah if you play
something use your phone yeah it's not
moving but now I'm losing yeah so here
instead of I can take him play with me
six then you play with Kate ah yeah much
probably ruki 685 rube b6 a4 that I
think would be a draw most probably even
though i'm torn down i don't think they
use still for white or black Oh a
blotchy I'm not so sure if it will be
that dangerous
takes
Brigade takes a 584 b 183 ok one oops
you right ahead yeah now I would just
break my looking at funk in his hand in
d6 can be three kinky hi so that's 44
and identity to be so don't think it was
just that big blunder after this I think
it was just crush you just exchange the
rooks and and and here i think it was
maybe route be one was asked you to
describe but what is it yeah seeing this
you know but I wasn't so sure what would
happen if I just play something like I
mean quite place but it's a doozy for
you all right maybe ask for and King f3
because when I take my king to be seven
you just broke actually said yourself
this is just draw how can I move my pawn
don't move to your power just make sure
yeah i mean i was thinking things black
has to try for a win oh yeah that's why
if I cannot do enter and this last three
is lovely yeah after this it's just like
zona yeah and the final international
master norm standings Brooks and
bergonzi tied at 6 apiece with kabuki
right behind and of course no norms in
this section either remember to keep up
with the action in st. Louis chess club
dork we're going to be having more of
these tournaments in the future this is
just the beginning and despite the
indecisive finish to this tournament the
Chess Club Invitational has opened new
doors and new possibilities